j'imagine qu'elle rende concentrer s'il
te plaît qu'est-ce que vous vous êtes
j'imagine ça serait plus gros pour un
maintenant suivre sa conscience
l'interdiction de 36 pesticides lui
permettra de retirer des tablettes se
produit qu'il n'ose même pas utilisé ça
va remplacer par des choses biologie
le glyphosate du principe de précaution
Valérie plante abolir à l'usage et la
vente 209 produits à base de pesticides
dans des néonicotinoïdes mortel pour les
abeilles le règlement devrait être
adopté en septembre et effectif des
janvier 2022
alors que on est
à Montréal
avec avec l'agriculture au Québec le mon
tour une façon de cohabiter les
municipalités québécoises réglementé
l'utilisation des pesticides sur leur
territoire pourvu qu'elle ne soit pas
plus permissive que la province et c'est
Jean-Philippe use Radio-Canada Montréal